もうプリンだよね…
まさき＜う～ん…
まさき＜染め…れば
染める
明るくするよ
はじめ＜こんちゃあああはじめしゃちょーです！
まさき＜こんちゃあああ＆＃%＄▽☆※
少し遅れたんですけども、
いよいよこの日が来ましたね
まさき＜はい
え～、なんやかんや
wwwwwwwwwww
まさき＜はじめしゃちょーたん
え~、なんやかんや、はじめしゃちょーチャンネル
僕、そしてまさきに手伝ってもらって、
ここまで来たんですけどもぉ、
今回新たに…
はじめ＜ま、新たにっていう訳でもないか
まさき＜うん
はじめ＜改めてですね、
まさき＜はい
改めて、新しいメンバーを紹介したいと思います
どうぞ！
ガシャ(扉を開ける音)
待って待って、これ別ｋ…
バックショットの方がいいな
どうぞ！
ドン！ドン！バン！ドン！(扉を開けた音)
うおぅっ！…
えっ、ちょっと待ってww
何があった何があったww
か…かづのような…
はじめ＜風のような上半身と
まさき＜シュ！
音しか聞こえなかったよ
はい、という訳で改めまして、たくみふくしゃちょーでーす！
パチパチパチパチパチ(拍手の音)
はじめ＜ホントおかえりなさいだよね
まさき＜おかえりなさいだよ
はじめ＜おかえりなさい！
たくみ＜ただいま！
たくみ＜こうなると思ってなかったよ…
はじめ＜いや、僕も思ってなかった
まさき＜う～ん
たくみ＜ちょっと期待してた…
wwwwwwwwwww
いろいろな事をわたくしも考えた末に、
彼の力を借りたいと思って、今回戻って来ていただい…
いただいたので、
バンバン！(胸を叩く音)
まさき＜ はい
今後はね、
彼の出演頻度も増えると思うので、
まさき＜はい
また、よろしくお願い致しますというお話でございます
まぁそうですね、
なんで、一応チャンネル名は今はじめしゃちょーに
なってるんですけども、
ひょっとしたら、形的には、
僕がＹouTube始めた頃のスタートですね、
はじめカンパニーという、
お恥ずかしい名前でやっていた時期もありましたが…
まぁそれに戻ったと言っても過言ではないと思っている私は
まぁ、わかんない、
僕もひょっとしたら一人で撮りたい…
時の動画もあるかもしれないし、
みんなで撮りたい動画もあると思うので、
はじめ＜協力し合って、
まさき＜はい
たくみ＜はい
まぁ適当に、
楽しくやっていければいいなと、思っております
まさき＜楽しみだね、なんか…
はじめ＜うん、楽しみ
たくみ＜楽しみだね
まさき＜またこの3人が…
まさき＜集まって出来るっていうのは…
はじめ＜確かに
まぁ、たぶん、ここ2人の事は結構、
みなさん知ってると思うんですけども、
たくみの事をひょっとしたら
知らない人も多いかもしれないので、
まさき＜あぁ…そうだね
ちょっと軽く自己紹介を…
ホント軽くていいんで
たくみ＜軽くでいいの
えっと…はじめと大学の時に会って、
これを、一番初めに、
最初に、はじめカンパニーが始まった時に居た内の1人です
で、昔の動画で、
たぶん、再生があったところで言うと、
自分が大学卒業する時の動画とかが
結構あったかなと…思います
はじめ＜卒業式だね
たくみ＜うん、卒業式だ
たくみ＜あれはガチ泣きの動画で…
はじめ＜うん…懐かしいな！
たくみ＜懐かしいよ！
はじめ＜ちょー懐かしい
たくみ＜あと、まさきをハメた動画とか
まさき＜そう、ゴリラの…ドッキリとかね
たくみ＜ゴリラ
はじめ＜あ～
たくみ＜人を信じられなくなったっていう…
wwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwww
たくみ＜で、長野に就職したん…ですよね
たくみ＜就職して、2年間働いてて、
たくみ＜その間は、プライベートではじめのとこに
遊びに来たりはするけど…
はじめ＜会社で働いてるからね…
たくみ＜うん…
はじめ＜でも、まだもうちょっと
たくみ＜もうちょっとだな…
はじめ＜もうちょっと
たくみ＜うん
はじめ＜やっぱいろいろこう…
はじめ＜引っ越しとか、
まさき＜うん
しなきゃいけない事もいろいろあるので、
すぐに、出まくるって訳でもないので、
まぁ、徐々に、
また動画に出てくると、思います！
はい、という訳で、特にこうなんか、
特別バッと変わる訳でもないんですけども、
まぁいろいろと、
今までに無いような動画も作っていければいいなと、
思っております！
はじめ＜ごめんね、課題中に…
はじめ＜今日はちょっと…
はじめ＜忙しいんだよ地味に！
たくみ＜俺もうニートだから
はじめ＜ニートなの
はじめ＜という訳で、
今後もがんばっていきましょぉおおお！！
たくみ＜いぇえええええええええええ！！
はじめ＜わあああああああああああ！！
まさき＜ああああああああああああ！！
たくみ＜いぇえええええええええええ！！
はじめ＜わあああああああああああ！！
まさき＜ああああああああああああ！！